[Music]
[Applause]
boom what is up everyone welcome to
simulation we have a very exciting show
it's our first time talking about time
banking and who better to have on the
show then dr. Edgar Khan and I need a B
Berg thank you so much for joining us on
the show greatly appreciate it thank you
thank you and okay this is awesome
because we kind of have like the
old-school founder of time banking you
know the original and then we have save
exchange which is now taking time
banking to this new level and I really
like how we can have we're gonna have
that conversation tonight okay so let's
start you know let's start with a let's
go with like a 101 intro you know time
banking is very kind of like you know
one one hour one credit so let's unpack
that a bit you know when the term
initially came to be and what that
really meant well time banking was a way
of creating a new kind of money this was
before the crypto currencies as a way of
really saying that volunteering was more
than volunteering that there was a whole
economy that underlay all that money
does it's called families neighborhoods
kinship groups communities civil society
and all it does is minor things like
raise children take care of the elderly
make democracy work and keep the planet
sustainable but nothing important to
understand and so when I neither
undertook to say let's take this to the
next level she was really talking about
unleashing a resource and a source of
labor that involved every hue
because one of the core principles on
the long time making is that all of us
have something to give something to do
that others need and if we're going to
create the kind of world that we want
that's not for a few people doing the
work that's all of us helping to build
the village it takes to raise the child
you've got to build I always say it
takes and you always use that when I'm
talking about save exchange it's not
only takes a village to raise a child
but it takes a village to have a person
thrive in this world to have someone
back you up yeah so I mean there is a
lot of talk right now that social issues
about like you universal basic income
and all along I have actually if you
look at some articles I've written about
universal basic income that it's not
just if you just throw money to people
some people think yes that's the way to
solve the problem but I think what
fundamentally we should do is look
within ourselves to help ourselves as
well as our own community and that
doesn't cost money so that was that was
what I had to really teach the London
School of Economics yeah as I had to do
the thinking that says how can you have
a currency that eliminates the regex
market price because in economics if
marginal benefit does not exceed
marginal cost nothing can survive what
that means is you got to get more than
you put in in order to keep doing it but
the marginal benefit that she's talking
about that I identify that the London
School of Economics was how we feel
about ourselves and how other people
look at us and so there was always
volunteering but when volunteers get
recognized and when what they do in an
effect enables them to get help for
themselves or to make or to use the
credits they earn to give to a
non-profit or they give some to somebody
else who may need it then you get a
multiplier effect and it's that
multiplier effect that convinced them
that I had found a way for marginal
Court
benefit to exceed marginal cost yes okay
so there's so much done I know this yes
let's okay let's start with with this
the you were talking about work with
London School of Economics there has
also been besides time banks USA have
also done a tremendous amount of work it
was the national legal services programs
for to end the war on poverty co-founded
back from the the Antioch School of Law
and that's at the University of the
District of Columbia so there's been a
tremendous amount of work that you've
been doing across other organizations
for the last 40 years has been of this
has walk the talk his whole life has
been you know service to others yes I'm
proud of him he actually changed the
course of history if anyone in terms of
lost students anyone is a law student
hours ever you know gone to law school
he created the lock clinics that you
actually have to go out there and you
know do it first before you just study
about it in theory to become a lawyer
you can go about that well it was my
legacy because my father taught me that
justice was too great an abstraction but
and platonic but that we were all born
with a sense of injustice with an
ability to respond to disparities that
we should not tolerate so the definition
of justice he gave me was the process of
either preventing or remedying whatever
would trigger our sense of injustice and
for me time banking is a way of
addressing the disparities the
fundamental disparities that should not
be tolerated and that we do not need to
accept perfect entry into what we what
the next part of what I wanted a touch
on was which is you both started
speaking on in terms of kind of of
society and and of community and of the
way that we've evolved and there's the
way that we evolved with the money
hasn't been recognizing the way that we
as communities function in terms of
raising children taking care of elderly
volunteer work that the whole civil
lunch okay so now hustle yeah okay so I
think that a good way to maybe address
this would be the way that you started
you know ed agreed you mentioned this to
me when you walked in really quickly in
it you know it definitely expanded my
awareness it was really important that
technology has built trust because if we
were to have met a thousand two thousand
years ago it would have been easy for us
even a couple hundred years ago to just
kind of Bop ourselves over the head take
your take your goods and that's it
there's no footprint there's no paper
trail of you or paper trail of me really
now there's the social network graph if
I'm not on social networks for a week or
if I'm not on texting or calling for a
week people already know that and they
know where I am at and all this other
kind of stuff so now it's become
different so maybe we touch on how we
went with community to now with
technology and where we're going with
where we need to be if I had to use a
paper card index to find out who is
available Tuesday night to babysit or
help my kid with homework
I'd be going through index cards so the
whole digital revolution that the
internet that first the computers made
possible and then that the Internet is
made accessible on smartphones enables
us to radically reduce the time it takes
to build trust and to build oh and to
see what the footprints are if a person
has done something bad they leave
footprints if they don't show up if
they're late that becomes part of their
track record yes and so what that made
it possible to begin to trust strangers
at a rate that exceeded anything that
history permitted that's so fascinating
blockchain is all about that right
immutable trust yes and I mean we are
you
traditionally our time banks communities
were closed communities they would trade
within their own exchange within
themselves we want to use blockchain and
then open it up to the world so now you
have one global community trading within
each other they can still have coasts
you know I don't want to say systems but
that's where they are closed systems
like a school like in my case I'm a mom
at a parent participation school we have
to volunteer you know a certain number
of hours every week but they can't have
Outsiders necessarily volunteer because
we have enumerable we have to have TV
shots background checks and you know we
don't want a stranger coming in to you
know just teach our child whatever they
we have to do so there's some security
things but I mean that's that's why we
have two systems we want to keep the
traditional time bank system where it
can be closed for those that need to
have it that way
especially if it's for informal
healthcare if you want someone driving a
patient again you have to check their
drivers license record but then for
other things because there's different
types of volunteering you don't need to
have all of those extensive background
checks just to show up at an event at a
campaign event so we have different
levels of trust and that's why we've a
blockchain is going to help us with that
having two different systems and with
time banking we've always had the time
credit so every each hour you volunteer
is equal if equivalent to one time
credit which you can then redeem for an
hour of service for yourself so we're
not changing that part we want to keep
that because we already have communities
all over the world and we don't want to
just pull the rug out of them but now
we're introducing crypto and with with
crypto what we're going to do is now
people have the option let's say I've
accumulated 50 time credits and I don't
need 50 hours for myself sure maybe one
or two I can keep but let's say this
many hours I don't need I can use that
now convert them into saver coins by the
way save amines volunteer in cents risk
so it's a save exchange volunteer
exchange so now what I can do is I can
don't
those hours that I volunteered to an
institution of my choosing it could be
between back to the school could be to
my church it could be to Habitat for
Humanity humanity so we're doubling the
impact of volunteerism so the people who
say well you know the whole point of
volunteering is just to give your time
well then fine
don't don't redeem your credits just
donate them to someone else who really
could use that time so that's you know
the only criticism I get is that safebut
volunteer is about just giving of
yourself so go ahead and do that but
there's others who really do have needs
you're really reinventing volunteerism
as you're speaking I'm totally seeing it
and you made it clear there's usually
silos for voluntary vertical and those
are vertical under the auspices of a
professionally dominated maybe
non-profit or government agency and
she's creating a whole horizontal flow
yes and this makes it easy like you said
okay if accumulated time credits now I
want to donate them to my Institute
whatever entities I want also to do
things like take time credits from
different plant place and move them
around take volunteers depending on like
you were saying earlier as well if there
needs to be significant background check
on the volunteer because it has to do
with children or has to do with
something very important then yes then
check but otherwise sometimes it's you
know you know feeding some people or
yeah and then that might not require the
extensive so it's might be easier to get
a volunteer for that position okay so
that ecosystem is is actually huge so I
explained the blockchain part right now
explain the time credits now I want to
talk about the AI come folks okay but
before we get to the I component which
is which is important and we will
address that there is a there's a very
important philosophical question to ask
along the way that question is time
banking is built on the idea that my one
hour of of helping you write your book
is as a volunteer is equivalent to the
person that spent an hour making a chair
and
so these sort of ideas now mate now is
it possible that that someone that
volunteered writing code for a company
that that our or that credit is worth
more than if I just you know put soup
into a bowl or so I wanted to talk about
AI so what we're doing is we're not
saying to someone hey a lawyers a lot of
people say my I'm a lawyer my time is
worth more than a cook okay but that's
not what we're doing with our
algorithmic skills matching you know we
can show our products like you know a
person creates their profile they list
the skills they want to volunteer for if
you're a lawyer and you can
you're not gonna if you don't want to
give your an hour of law service but hey
I actually like to paint murals you know
I would love to do that for someone
that's my hobby then volunteer that so
we're gonna match the skills that a
volunteer wants to give right with the
critical needs of a person but there's
another frame to it to respond to you
let me give two ways we're talking about
that my slice of eternity is not worth
more than yes so that that's okay so
that principle is what we're building
this conversation on social through
their code even though the market might
value it as as a $200 an hour or
something that you know later talking
about volunteered time not professional
time okay but think it's a skill set
that is much more in demand than someone
putting on and think of what it meant to
reject market price market value what
market value is depending on supply and
demand so if it's scarce if it's rare
it's very valuable if it's more abundant
as cheaper if it's really abundant it's
dirt cheap or worthless when I suddenly
realize that man being a human being was
worthless all of the capacities there's
a seven and a half billion human being
so it's not technically infinitely
abundant like areas it's all the time
they have and all the time future
generations will have if we preserve the
planet and to keep it sustainable and
all of that all of that time
is is is in fact of infinite is
priceless and what we've said is that
interesting so time is priceless
yeah the to devalue our fundamental
capacities to listen to each other to
care for each other to come to each
other's rescued to stand up for it's
right to mobilize to preserve the planet
all of that time is priceless we didn't
pay minimum wage for demonstrations to
stop the Vietnam War or to fight
segregation or the changes archive
that's right that was not a minimum wage
job that was people going out in the
thousands tens of thousands to oppose
certain prints of values as giving a
chunk of their life to give a chunk of
their life in their time for for to
change the direction of priceless and
that's when you look back at your life
you ask yourself what have I done
and how have I just and why am I here
and how do I justify the time that I've
spent and if it's all about selling and
buying in at market values I have in
fact devalued what it meant to be a
human being
Wow okay this is very profound and we
need it we need to cover it for just a
little longer so holy cow okay so if you
look at yeah this is really pulling down
[Laughter]
I agree with that so okay so time being
priceless so my slice of eternity or and
that I live in here right this beautiful
at this moment is no more or less
valuable than anyone elses moment and
then that same 80 years my 80 years no
more or less valuable than someone
else's so that first principle and then
that there's a second sort of principle
is this
we're revaluing what we call what we
honor as work
the third is there's a pay it forward
reciprocity when we talk about the core
values built into the entity we're
changing the operating system that the
undergirds the whole money
system because nothing would have
happened for the civil rights or the
fight against war or whatever it would
have it wouldn't have occurred if people
were like I need to get paid a minimum
wage to go and yeah and right about your
children who raised you to go and you
know teach you the values to go out
there right what about the mom who spent
all those hours they I mean I mean I
know personal experience so many times
moms have to give so much of our time
and we for the detriment of our career
and I'm actually going to be addressing
that in our app so now what we can do is
you go and volunteer you'll be you know
given a positive review for every hour
you do I mean if you have a positive
review and now we can take all of those
let's say our volunteer a hundred hours
I have a hundred positive reviews I can
launch my career in something I'm
passionate about and I'm not you know
ruining my career to volunteer see with
the sake of coin she's really adding a
whole new dimension but you see when you
change the characteristics of a medium
of exchange you change the dynamics
think of a grading system as a currency
when you change from pass/fail to 4.0
you change the whole dynamics in a
classroom yes when you give community
service credits in other words the way
in which we design the medium of
exchange we use to recognize work to
value work and to create the ability to
define yourself by what you've done and
what you've earned that meeting with
change sends out a whole new dynamic
because of the changes and so she's
changing the characteristics of how we
use time and how we value time okay this
is again this is starting to just like
eat into me more be here on this they
see how this this is this notion of you
know of money we we didn't evolve
without any other said we haven't tried
other systems we you know the first
thing that people come to mind is trying
to like bash communism or socialism that
seems to be like the first thing and
then there's never there's never a
conversation rarely a conversation about
oh well what new system could we try
that that you know and that's kind of
what this conversation is about is what
is time banking how can it potential
be a new system that it enables us with
things like potential universal basic
income and all this kind sell now now I
want to pull up time banks's website
because you guys this is really
important to showcase as well as we get
to some of the save exchange stuff so
we're on you see the time banks you got
it over there yeah cool so alright one
of the first things that I saw here that
I thought was really important to
highlight was these five core values of
time banking so okay 1988 account
dreamed up new kind of money and money
would have no price every hour would
come same one hour one hour okay and
then we talked about social justice and
how this really enabled people to go and
they didn't get paid minimum wage they
just went and invest their time into
changing the path of civilization so no
more throwaway people and you've
authored how many books now
well at least three and then all kinds
of articles and law reviews and yes and
magazines and the latest one is in a
Jewish spiritual magazine Taccone how we
really need to redefine the value and
how accept allowing money to be the
dominant and exclusive way in which we
talk cost benefit and risk analysis and
they've really imprisons us in in a way
of determining what's possible yes it
imprisons us and it doesn't enable our
creativity to expand out of what exists
outside of the system that we haven't
yet tried okay so the normal no more
throwaway people is very interestingly
analogous to the war on normal people
yeah you take there's very interestingly
right there I don't think we'll get to
his vision unless of universal income
until we begin to understand that people
have an obligation to give to pay it
forward we all inherited what past
generations had electricity the internet
the food ubiquity in water yeah and so
and the village that it takes won't
exist if we don't all put in light pay
it forward and so we as when it is
recognized and validated that every
human being can contribute something
needed by somebody else a fifth-grader
can help a third-grader learn the
alphabet juveniles can run a youth court
that radically reduces recidivism
seniors can help other seniors stay out
of a nursing home but they can but
grandparents can also help raise
grandchildren if the parents are working
or if the family is in some way
dysfunctional so we need to create
relationships and networks of trust and
that's what saver is really undertaking
to do and that's why it's got the name
of those okay
there was only knocks we're talking
about something both very new but we
couldn't have done it in the caves what
we found out was that if we didn't begin
to help each other when one when the
mate got killed if somebody else didn't
look after the kids so really in our DNA
is looking out for each other and
thinking about what who's going to take
care of the future generations and is
there going to be a world that for the
future generations
so so very like the cave it came first a
lot of the evolutionary pressures that
brought us here today were at times very
violent ones and I think we're moving in
a direction like you said of
transcending that and moving towards a
time of figuring out how to care for
things like the hours that people spend
on child-raising on community work on
that kind of stuff so the five core
values asset every one of us has
something of value to share with someone
else
you know redefining work there are some
forms of work that money will not easily
pay for like building strong families or
vitalizing neighborhoods making
democracy work advancing social justice
time credits were designed to reward
recognize and honor that work you could
spend weeks and months of your time
making no money but progressing social
norms to advance and progress and so
this is a very old system where I'll
call the old operating system devalue
particularly those kinds of work and
particularly the work of women of
immigrants of children of elderly and we
need that's why we need to honor that as
real work we need to validate it we need
to root we need to upgrade our perceive
our perception of it but then there's a
pay it forward piece if I help you I
feel good but how do you feel you feel
grateful but if all you if the only way
you can define yourself as somebody in
need of help you don't have any way of
feeling as good as I feel so built into
this is the notion that when you receive
help the way in which you pay back is to
show that you're is capable of giving
help and you have capacity to help
others so we are equal you are not
subordinate I am grateful to you for
accepting the help I can give and the
way in which you can pay me back is to
show that you have the same ability so
that every act beacon sends in motion
the ripples of a pond that happens when
you throw a pebble in the pond and this
is what you were mentioning earlier with
the youth when you have a child that
just needs a tiny bit of guidance to
help them avoid violence and gangs but
rather focus on art or music or sport
that that is a tiny little shift that
that that pay it forward from a high
schooler to a to a younger middle
schooler or elementary school kid or
from a mentor to a student of any sort
that is so important it already exists
but we want to be able to connect all
the dots and make it a formal eCos
so acts of volunteering get forgotten
they get evaporated what she's doing is
taking that volunteering and giving it a
digital life that enables it to continue
to exist you have force yes in the
digital world is like we were talking
about earlier with footprints and the
tech building trust is now the digital
world is enabling time making to really
flourish oh how much you don't have to
go through the old yeah when you're
looking for a babysitter yeah look at
all the different cards who's available
call the people and that's why my social
network serves as a core value because
it what it is explicit is yeah that's we
had a whole ethos of everybody for
themselves you gotta prove yourself and
pick yourselves up by your own
bootstraps well I came into this earth
nine months in debt and so I got to pay
it forward out propositions in debt yeah
when you're a baby right nine months
nine months you're in the in the womb
yeah so you're nine months in the
hospital when you come out how is that
we but how is that dead well we've all
had an obligation I think to take care
of them that's already sign up for this
no I don't know anybody and I'm I want
five hundred dollars just to get out of
bed in the morning okay yes so okay so
that so that's an interesting counter to
that is we have to all be bore all seven
that billion of us have to agree that
that I have an obligation nine months in
debt when I'm born that I'm gonna have
to pay it forward because I was in a
labor of mothering and the labor of
raising a child has all been forgotten
there's all been you're basically born
into a shelter almost always you're born
into water and food and electricity
almost always now we're getting there
and so because of that you are
technically then in gratitude you are
you want to give back you want to pay it
forward for the next generations by you
know building and so that's okay so we
did we went reciprocity social networks
and respect this was actually really
interesting because I recently learned
this we're hosting a women in Alliance
event tomorrow
night and we're featuring very powerful
women to have discussion about the
what's going to be happening in this
transition as we have women coming into
power and it's amazing I have this at
this point that I was taught about
respect which is that that we actually
don't want to be loved we want to be
respected and I thought I was very
interesting because I totally feel that
now more than ever especially with women
and now I'm trying to take that also
into you know into elderly and into
parents and in take children versus wild
love as a form of love yes yes it's also
critical respect means of feedback group
you have to be open to hearing what
other people think are saying or hurting
even if you don't want to so without a
feedback respect really says we have to
build into the the systems we have the
voice of the people whom were helping
who may tell us what you're doing done
make sense we need that as a corrective
built in yeah and that's why that had to
be added to the core values yes these
are really strong core values and tight
and this is again it's just time banks
to work everyone the links in the bio go
check it out
really easy to find the time bank near
you or start one and really get rolling
into understanding what this is like and
where it's going in a future and then
there we also have another link in the
bio which is gathering with the purpose
dotnet and why don't you speak about
this as we continue yeah so anyone who's
interested in time banking we really
want people to first actually go to this
site because we're offering materials
that they can try out I mean instead of
just joining a time making community and
then saying wow this is not for me and
quitting start your own with a few
friends it's that's why it's called
gathering with the purpose and Edgar's
way because the threshold investment you
have to make to build a non-profit can
be a barrier and but my wife Chris
created gathering with a purpose because
to pull five or six or fifteen people
together and just and
have them exchange and then to have them
go through a process of subsequent
workshops and begin to learn about time
banking and then say maybe we'll do this
maybe we won't but but it's a much lower
threshold of entry entry into the ideas
and the values that's really important
actually we want we're actually trying
to raise funds to do a film on gathering
with the purpose where you know we will
follow maybe five or six people in DC
because that's where they're from where
all walks of life and you know it
doesn't matter and then we bring them
together and followed them for a few
weeks as Chris will teach the course and
then wait a month and then follow them
and say how do you feel about time being
is this something for you and we want it
to be raw you know not we're not forcing
them to say yeah we're gonna do it but
it's a good way that it's like a a peek
at this is what it is because though
people don't it sounds great to everyone
but it really isn't necessarily for
everyone you know we hope it is but I I
wish we could spend a lot more time
talking about you know about what's
about the way that capitalism dances
with time banking I wish we could pass
more time on that well would capitalism
dancing with time making what are you
saying there what do you do yeah
whatever I sighs I know you don't want
to spend too much that's right what does
one thing to say about that yeah so what
we're doing with the crypto component is
we're partnering with you know company
called mana base that's offering
universal basic income we're partnering
with another company that's trying to
offer starting with simple insurance you
know travel health anything I mean
eventually will be larger things and
they're using threw coins we're
partnering with another company who's
doing affordable housing so what you can
do now is earn volunteer by volunteering
you earn our coins you cannot buy our
coins you have to earn them or it's you
know you can donate them you could buy
it to donate but now now once you've
earned them you can go on and trade that
coin for universal basic income should
you anything affordable housing anything
that you would think that you know the
government
maybe should offer we're gonna thats how
we're using capitalism too you know
that's the dance that's it yeah okay so
so I go and volunteer my time and I earn
a save a coin and then I can take save a
coin and get whatever basic needs that I
need to live and and even pass that
whatever is being offered by the company
so then those other companies are then
taking the save a coin and then they are
how do they continue their operations
how do they like grow and with save we
want to build the largest volunteer
exchange Network so for them it's also
you know people get to it's a more
exposure for them as well so because we
already have communities we've we have
them globally so for them at this stage
and their thing they need to you know
educate more and more people about other
things like universal basic income so I
mean it's a mutual thing
you know we want to help well well how
would they sustain okay if I if I have
ten people that work on a project that I
take save a coins to provide the product
for people through save a coin how do I
cover the living expenses of the ten
people that work at the company if I
accept safer I think you should
interview them next thing they'll tell
you the details but they are offering to
about a hundred thousand people their
own joy manna coin manna coins okay yeah
so this is not dollars they're not
making universe basic income in in fiat
currency we are going to be living as we
have now in two worlds the world of
money and the
I didn't invent the world of non money
yet around like from the beginning of
time and so but the question is how we
keep that world vital how we enable it
to grow if you had to pay for everything
your parents did you'd be in oh yeah
and particularly even at minimum wage
right and so that's a good quote you
have to pay for everything your parents
did that's a good one zero to 18 you did
nothing pretty much you went to school
and that kind of stuff but but you they
provided everything for you yeah Jesus
so capitalism looks at what money can do
we're looking at what money doesn't do
and we're trying to say that the
economic value the significance of that
cannot be underestimated anymore that
for even for capitalism to thrive
it needs vibrant communities it means
Trust it means children who grow up with
something weird called the work ethic
and principles of your honor your
promises and you do it you know and you
don't break rules that and you don't
hurt other people so they you need a
more any economic system needs a moral
order and an ecosystem that nurtures the
growth and reinforcement of that what
we're talking about with saver is a
medium of exchange that can reinforce
that and can combine it with both
intrinsic rewards how you feel about
yourself how you recognize and enter
extrinsic reward how you get discounts
how you get bargains how you get access
to events those two looking lives
side-by-side the way the nonprofit world
has all great that down for us you know
how can those two give us an example
tell you this we have you know our
intrinsic rewards obviously it's always
there when you volunteer I feel good
right the extrinsic rewards can be the
the saver coins the credits it's also
could be like gamification Wow
I mean I can earn a whole bunch of these
credits to certain people that means
something but here look at your nose
loans that community service can give
loan forgiveness and you could earn loan
forgiveness and what you get is a more
educated person who can give back the
expertise that they've developed in
return for use of that money we need to
have we need to experiment with new ways
in which those two systems can live side
by so totally totally let's experiment
and let's figure out absolutely what
what are the new creative ways of
thinking that have yet to be yeah
Habitat for Humanity doesn't and saver
will open it up to a whole of a scale so
here so here's a question so we have
someone that is getting intrinsically
rewarded for doing volunteer work then
they get an extrinsic reward they get a
save a coin and they can spend it where
they want okay so those are the entry I
we're also doing impactful thing that's
another motivation previously if you
know you'd volunteer maybe it's not you
know you're just a state we just need a
hundred people to come to this event
maybe you could just sign people in but
now we're actually imagine this in my
case I actually teach ceramics the AI is
gonna make everything so much easier
no but it's we're creating impact when
you I mean I can even make the case for
myself and this is might be extreme okay
I love to teach ceramics to children but
now I have suddenly been matched to a
child who you know maybe [ __ ] that
person has cancer and their last wish is
to make something for their mom and they
just you know that's the last wish and I
get matched to that damn that's a big
impact isn't it it's not just oh I'm
just making pottery that's actually one
of the biggest impacts on that person's
life yeah so that's what we're trying to
do we're creating impact through AI and
we're using technology to advance like
all of the things that we couldn't
necessarily do because of bureaucracy
we're gonna you know we don't need to
worry about it anymore so so the story
that you gave there are you know
trillions of these types of stories and
so to fill the write invented volunteer
Network
to the the proper position that needs to
be of the one of these trillions of
scenarios
that's crucial and to have algorithms
that enable that at more effective rates
and that's that's amazing
there's still something about this that
I wanted to press afterward which was
that when I have an intrinsic and
extrinsic reward intrinsic being feeling
amazing and extrinsic being a save a
coin I can also look at you know maybe a
capitalism option which is I build a you
know a product or service that that
enables me to feel like okay I built
something and that makes me feel loved
other people to get it they pay coin or
money or whatever it is for it then they
feel loved I'm just trying to put these
into a mixing pot well you know see how
it flourishes then you need to look at
co-op I cannot a cooperative effort if I
can coops because those are a
combination and our labor and investment
but they also have money but but if
you're if you remember of a co-op and
get some discounts and that's right and
so we're not the first to try and
understand that sweat equity or to give
you some return number it turns yeah
yeah and the sweat equity is also
evident in the the Silicon Valley
entrepreneur structure as well people
getting sweat equity for joining
companies and stuff like that okay so
now I think you know you mentioning
coops I think has helped you make some
more sense thank you Ron I'll flip over
our little 15-minute timer so there's
still so much more to understand about
how these things can evolve together
I'm extremely open-minded on a show and
always trying to unpack really high
quality nuance around what the evolution
of this would look like and how how
people can explore it and understand it
and so you know it's what's really tough
to go if we were a lot saver
would provide the the digital path but
supposing every government grant and
contract required in kind match in
citizen participation hours using saver
to monitor those and document them that
would mean that all the nonprofit's were
not only service providers that they
became catalysts or they partnered with
several organizations or time banks to
mobilize think what a transformative
impact that would have on every attempt
to invest in some and addressing of some
kind of social problem it would be
massive and there's no limit because
we're spending billion years but what's
the return on those billions and if the
return were billions of hours documented
then then the nonprofit's themselves
would have a stronger case to go back
for funding and the programs that they
care about would have a people based
constituency to tell their congressman
you better keep funding that nonprofit
because I'm doing because I'm partnering
with them to produce the kinds of social
good that you want to produce and this
is a massive market what was the key
pull up the slide that has the market on
it that slide numbers one hundred forty
billion four hundred and ten four
hundred and ten billion dollars that's
just the u.s. that's the tech which we
talked about the tech a little bit with
the blockchain ledger so this is just in
the u.s. this is just in the u.s. last
year in two thousand do we know how many
volunteers that is is that millions of
oh we have sixty three million
volunteers and they we think it's about
one in four people in the u.s. one in
four they're saying volunteer and that's
about eight billion hours per year in
the u.s. so it's a lot of hours eight
billion hours that's a lot it were in
Wales the Minister of Health changed all
grants and contracts had to have my
in creating some kind of informal
network of the patients and the families
in the community had had to create those
networks and they used time banking to
do many of them used to uh making to do
that others use other means but the
notion that the money that we spend to
solve problems or to have a multiplier
effect could function as a catalyst if
you had a currency that honored that
work and documented yeah I'm enabled
honored it and they will do the channel
attract it and focus it yes and that's
where we're heading okay okay now let's
let's talk about a little bit more on
future side of things because what
time's coming too close I want to make
sure we talk about this so it seems as
though evolution went from the small
tribal and communal gangs that we were
able to just you know more simply do
what we wanted to do and get it done to
now with seven and a half billion people
it makes it more difficult for us to
figure out how to value things the
tougher things to value that markets
aren't valuing right now so with the
future as we progress into things like
exploring universal basic income
exploring this massive reinvented
volunteer network and algorithms that
can pair people up blockchain technology
that enables all this where yeah where
were we headed that with the different
text acts that we have that are making
this happen and universal basic income
if I get a thousand bucks a month and I
might am I gonna spend more time you
know create creating things as well as
going in volunteering how do we see that
role playing answer okay for me I would
say you know we've always been able to
give we already already give all intere
time but now we want to motivate more
people to recruit everyone everyone
gives time to a buddy helps somebody out
but we want to you know we want to
acknowledge that in our system and give
you something for it well
that you can then you know get when you
help your buddy move or you help you
know all of those hours count we don't
even think about that yeah but when you
hold the door open for like 10 seconds
you know it's an hour it's an hour if
you only for an hour okay we're giving
our credit so these are very interesting
it's like how do you define what how
many minutes or whatever and how and
that kind of how do you define as
something as a Valen Valen tear credit
well that's why we want to keep the time
banking communities we have you know
someone who is the was a time making
coordinator so that person in the time
banking community they can you know
verify the exchange or they could first
of all they can there with blood team we
don't need it but that's what was
happening that the time making
coordinator could you know if the
exchange wasn't happening and somebody
needed something and it wasn't being
matched manually the time bank
coordinator stepped in and said oh I
know someone who can help you and they
would do the calls so we're actually
we're not trying to get rid of the time
bank or dinner we we think that role is
very very important especially now we're
gonna be expanding to nonprofits and
there should be a role and that's called
the volunteer manager and they will be
able to verify some of these credits
it's not but we understand there's two
systems okay again there's going to be a
time banking system and I wanted to
explain this because it's very confusing
to people but if nonprofits are willing
to use our system they can get more
volunteers you know and then retain
their volunteers but now what they're
gonna do is offer to their volunteers
another system saying hey all the
volunteers let's say at the YMCA we're
letting you use our platform to exchange
time with with your your own community
you're with each other you're all belong
to the ymc let's exchange time with each
other so you come give us some time at
the YMCA and volunteer at our nonprofit
but but we're also offering you a way to
get your credits back and for yourself
so in that case the volunteer manager
will verify that yes this person
actually came to our campaign event and
helped out maybe with a blood drive or
whatever it is
then you'll verify that and time bank
communities the what is it called a time
bake coordinator is the one who verified
it
now think about veterans benefits you've
heard of yeah and veterans for their
service yes
get mortgages get discounts get access
to higher education totally got the GI
Bill so if you if you take it from
veterans to uh persons who provide
service to community via time banking
think of what the implications of that
could be if they could earn access to
student loans if they could earn access
to mortgages at lower interest rates if
they could earn more loan forgiveness if
they could and enable are there kids to
get to to get into colleges that
otherwise they couldn't afford the
implications of this are are open-ended
because the currency will drive as money
drives the creation of multiple systems
a new medium of exchange will drive many
many systems we've already seen a driver
system for people coming out of prison
who wake up in the morning to provide
safe passage of course gang territory
for kids to come to go to school come
back from school and that was
short-lived but it was very effective
while it lasted so we need to get people
understanding you need to get
philanthropy to understand that
investing in this kind of endeavor
because you needed an infrastructure and
the nonprofits need to survive but we
need to change the framework from what
I'll call the unilateral delivery of
service to partnerships with time banks
and saver will provide us with a new a
new level of that makes time banking
even more attractive I think because it
will have saver coins the world that
will expand its volunteer pool it's
you're gonna be trading not just within
a smaller community you're gonna you
could trade with the world you could go
on a vacation
usually you know trade your save a coin
and you can go anywhere this is what we
want to do this yeah you brought up very
important points veterans the amount of
service they put in and then the GI Bill
makes total sense the case with with
them with anybody that invests their
time to get some sort of a benefit from
that and an extrinsic benefit which is
the reward of a save a coin okay let's
ask a couple questions on as we and
there are probably really important
pieces they're definitely really
important pieces that we didn't get to
do you do you have one that comes to
mind that you think we definitely need
to address well I think the important
thing if I haven't said it it's we keep
talking about the rewards but I want to
talk about those people you know who
don't necessarily they're they're very
lucky in life and they just like to
volunteer I want to encourage them to
still do our system because you're
doubling your impact okay that's really
important we keep saying yes you'll get
rewarded but there are people who out
there who do it and these could be
churches this could be religious
institutions they believe that you
should just serve for the sake of it
then I say please go ahead and do that
join our system and double your impact
and then give it to someone else in need
those hours yeah I think the thing I
would want to add is that we need from
early on to build us into the
educational process elementary school
kids can make a difference in my law
school we give a course in system change
we're the only law school that does that
I think we need to build a course of
study that every college student takes
in understanding systems and
understanding how to leverage and change
systems by enlisting the people whom the
system is designed to help as co-workers
and co-producers of outcomes so and so I
think that we're talking about a radical
change in education but that the digital
age maids all that makes all that
possible
well we have community service
requirements now in high schools even
low as low to middle schools and
colleges of this is perfect for them
because now there's a trail of all the
hours that person is put in Boy Scouts
whatever they do it can leave a trail so
that person instead of leaving all your
selfies and the crazy things you've done
let's say instead you have a digital
footprint of all the great things you
did in life from you know starting at
age five helping out you know appear
another five year old I mean that is
amazing wouldn't you rather have that
than a drunken photo of you an
embarrassing thing of you that's what I
want people to do I want to move past
the selfie generation and create the
next selfless generation in the media
and video could be will play a critical
role in that because we need the stories
and we need that built into the news and
we need new kinds of local heroes and
heroines and we need to celebrate that
so we're talking about a culture shift
that really involves not just do
something that either hurts people it
makes money we need different kinds of
headlines we need to celebrate people
who contribute like a huge mover and
shaker in the community one that is
coming back a lot in the community the
highest ranking of volunteers in the
network that are just earning tons of
hours and that they're going and
exchanging they're donating their save
the coins and exchanging them and for
services and they have great stories
that we can tell that's a whole culture
shift you know all the grandmother in
the neighborhood everybody knows and
counts on yeah that's a good legged drop
their kids off with that they can drop
we didn't cover this but depression I
mean and we actually can in and time
banking has proved that because we're
building a community if somebody's
depressed they you know they have this
community out there they give their time
and it leave here it's your own
depression because now you're not
thinking about your own self go and then
there's no I guess there's no the whole
money thing also kind of messes
psychiatry a bit and yes a new studies
are showing the impact of social
isolation is as dangerous to health and
smoking yeah that's right and so it's
almost a public health issue with
isolation and there is also a different
kind of isolation there's like the
obsession with digitisation and then
there's also the obsession with I guess
when you just get obsessed with one item
of knowledge or just knowledge in
general and then you don't socialize as
much which I don't know exactly where
that involves with autism spectrum and
stuff but I don't necessarily think that
isolation in maybe in its completest
form where you're never talking to
anybody that could be horrible we're
actually partnering with it come it's it
for autism for children it's called pred
Nia it's actually one of my Frant good
friends let's do pregnant yeah so you
know excite any nonprofit any society's
ill they they have a non-profit to help
those type of people bring them in have
those children give ours to other
children because pregnant is all about
that helping children socialize with
other children who are also on the
autism specialist so so what does it
what does it look like when time is no
longer seen as a linear thing I don't
know he can answer that it sounds very
theoretical to me well I think if I
certainly talking about enhancing the
qualitative experience of time we all
know that some hours are special in some
hours or not the more we can make hours
precious because of the impact they've
had and because the way in which they
reinforce our sense of self I think
there's a universal hunger to feel that
you matter that what you that your
existence has some significance
and so we can we change the meaning of
time when we enhance it with experience
that validates ones one's own sense of
hey I'm here for a purpose and I'm here
to find that purpose and to fulfill it
and I'm not alone and people and I can
find other people who work with me if I
work with them okay and in okay this is
that's so good so because this leads
into one of the questions that we asked
on the show a lot on our kind of on our
way out which is if we think that we're
alone in the cosmos what do you guys
think about that is it's not religious
question oh my guess is that we're not
and that learning how to live with each
other is so we may be in some
interplanetary intergalactic school and
we may be in kindergarten learning how
to play with each other and then we may
graduate I love thinking about it that
way - that's so good it's funny all the
answers closest to the truth
Wheatley chuckle at that's what I've
recently noticed when people really hit
the nail on the head
we are are we actually in an
intergalactic kindergarten and that
there are forces outside of Earth could
be a playground illusionary processing
no we have to good get graduate into
first grade yeah exactly gradually I get
into first grade in the first yeah
exactly
I'm glad that I said it sounds like
you've thought about this I like it well
you see it doesn't it doesn't frighten
me because then what would Higher
Education look like and what would you
know we don't understand yet our own
minds but we do know that in terms of
the synaptic connections in the brain
that we have more synaptic
actions in the brain than there are
stars in the universe that's a lot of
untapped capacity we don't know about
telepathy we don't know about Mela
Kinesis we don't there's so much we
don't know about just about mind body
I'm not supposed to be alive at the age
of 44 I had a heart attack in 1980 that
blew away 60% of my heart
they gave me two years and two hours
maybe in a day when I would function and
it was an intensive care that I dreamed
up time biking I'm now 83 I had a bonus
for three years ago Psalm 83 going on 15
and I'm almost ready to become an adult
not yet not yet wow that is incredible
that you live twice as long after that I
was 44 or me Wow and and so we don't
remember maybe my body yeah yeah we do
and we don't yeah that's that are very
clear that having a person I'm here
alive with 85% yield because my spirit I
had a reason to get up and you're easy
like a difference yeah or the trying
negative just a piggyback on the the
alone question is if you guys think
we're in a simulation is that way it's
cold snows wondering oh one of the
matrix
I believe it you don't want to unpack
that more no I was kidding I don't I
don't even want to make a comment on
that honestly that's a good answer
anybody that says that that's it that's
a that's an educated answer right
no comment I choose to think this is the
real
and we have a we have a question that
would do what do you believe to be true
that you believe that less than 1% of
society believes to be true how do you
ask that question when we're already an
hour into the show what's the most
beautiful thing in the world
Edgar go with that one and forget the
last one what's the most beautiful thing
in the world ed we do like asking that
last one yeah not on this show all
capacity to love each other and trust
each other that's awesome
because it gives birth to all the
artistry to all of our desire to
preserve the planet all of our desire to
create the kind of world that will be
there for our grandchildren and
great-grandchildren and enable them to
contribute
we are trustees of our ability of that
asset our ability to love and to care
and to learn should ask him what's the
secret to living so long and I think
it's that childlike you know let him
answer it's a secret we all want to know
like how do you do it Edgar you have so
much energy more energy than I do well I
think I think my tradition brought me up
committed to the pursuit of justice
justice shall you pursue and my father
gave me a working definition of what
that meant of what justice meant and
that it was not an end state that it was
the process of preventing or remedy what
would all ours our sense of injustice
and what I see is that we do not value
human beings and know that we that we
have been corrupted and our vision has
been distorted by allowing money to be
the sole way in which we measure value
and that that that we have to have
corrective lenses put on to see them to
see the full awesome capacity of human
beings when you think of more neural or
synaptic connections and there are stars
in the universe that's pretty awesome we
need to understand how
how powerful that is and I think we're
here as stewards of that with a trusty
relationship in the earth yeah and
figuring out how to transcend money for
honoring human and respecting the human
is that's a that's a first-grader
that's a second-grader you know that's
that's way past kindergarten let's even
maybe burn that wow that's tough that's
a tough but it's very but everything's
possible and we're gonna get there are
you can help us yeah all right
huge mission with people like you using
media and the internet we have a new
chance for global awakening
yes absolutely what's been missing often
is hope and a sense of possibility and I
think that is now reawakening yeah
beautiful thing the world
I would say innocence and children
before all the hate and all the other
you know bickering comes in that's the
most beautiful innocence yeah before all
the pressures yeah I miss my kids at
that age children at that age are just
like yeah they're colorblind yeah
they're just it's everyone everything is
love
everything's love yeah wow this has been
such a great show I feel so blessed this
is such a such a pleasure thank you
again thank you guys thank you thank you
thank you later of course of course yes
so much to still learn and explore about
time banking visit the links in the bio
go and start getting involved and with
time baking exploring it understanding
it and as we move into the era of
cryptocurrency and blockchain this is
really gonna help us advance the goals
that we set what can exist outside of
the current infrastructure that we live
in what creative new worlds can we
manifest and live in so thank you again
for everyone for tuning in
what comment with your thoughts below
we'd love to hear from you also don't
just consume this go create go and make
cool things into the world going to
start with time making go and make blogs
make videos make them adjust go and
create with this thank you Ron for
producing and directing and thanks
everybody for tuning in we will see you
soon peace
[Music]